und bei mir im Studio ist nun Markus
kein sicherheits- und
verteidigungsexperte der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik einem
unabhängigen Think Tank der auf die
Bundesregierung berät einen schönen
guten Morgen erkannt die russischen
Behauptungen dass die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive interessant geplant ist
oder stattfinden wird hat dazu geführt
dass viele Menschen jetzt umgesiedelt
werden was hat es damit auf sich also so
genau wissen Sie wissen wie es nicht
weil die ukrainischen Behörden oder
Generalstab nicht Auskunft darüber
gegeben hat ob es diese ob diese
Offensive wirklich bevorsteht wir kennen
nur die russischen Angaben dazu und es
ist etwas ungewöhnlich dass die
russische Seite sozusagen die Stadt
Preis gibt wenn man das so sagen darf
weil die Tonalität gestern mal so
ungewöhnlich dass man sich zurückziehen
würde dass man in schwerem Fahrwasser
sei dass wenn sie Zivilisten evakuieren
würde
es gab russische militärblogger die ich
gestern noch gelesen habe die von einer
Finte sprechen zu sagen dass man die
Ukraine in die Falle locken wolle ob dem
so ist dass man dann sehen aber
zumindest ist ein sehr ungewöhnliches
Vorgehen im Kriegsverlauf halten sich
dann für wahrscheinlich und sie sagen
man kann es gerade schwer einschätzen
aber wäre die Ukraine dann überhaupt in
der Lage Person jetzt einzunehmen
sie müssten den Fluss überqueren von dem
gerade die Rede über
und dann tatsächlich große Legende
Gewinne machen und vor allem ob es dann
zu halten wird es steht drauf waren am
Blatt Putin hat gestern das Kriegsrecht
verhangen in diesem Gebiet und auch in
der Stadt was bedeutet das ganz konkret
für die Menschen dort es ist ja bereits
angeklungen ist schränkt die
Bürgerrechte ein die russische Behörden
die mentärbehörden wie die Zivilbehörden
haben größere Möglichkeiten auf die
zylisten zuzugreifen sie können die
Demonstrationsfreiheit einschränken die
Pressefreiheit einschränken sie können
gegebenenfalls Zwangsrekrutierung
vornehmen das wissen wir nicht wofür das
genau geplant ist war das Jahr sehr noch
sehr früh ist das wird jetzt erstmal
umgesetzt werden aber es erlaubt größere
Handlungsspielräume und das markiert zu
sein eine angespann die politische Lage
in der Region jetzt hat Russland gestern
einen neuen Oberbefehlshaber ernannt die
Kamikaze drohen
verbreiten Schrecken und Terror in der
Ukraine also eine neue Strategie der
Russen die bewerten Sie diese aktuell
dieses aktuelle umschwenken also nennt
sich sehen wir ein gemischtes Bild
einerseits das Vordringen der Ukraine
auf dem Boden wir haben es gerade
angesprochen den Vormarsch oder
Vormarsch die Gelände Gewinne nennen das
war der letzten vier Wochen die sich
jetzt ungefähr Sonnen im Sonnabend war
sie zuspitzen gleichzeitig sie haben es
in ihrer Moderation angesprochen die
Raketenangriffe auf die ukrainische
Infrastruktur von in die
energienfrastruktur 40 Prozent der
Infrastruktur sind zerstört es müssen
Stromlieferungen unterbrochen werden
stromkürzungen verkündet werden
sozusagen sehen wir sehr gemischtes Bild
an der Front auf dem Boden Fortschritte
für die Ukraine moderater an aber das
überwölbende Kriegsbild deutet nicht in
diese Richtung da gibt es doch noch
erhebliche Vorteile gerade bei der
Lufthoheit auf Seiten der Russen sie
haben gerade die Probleme mit der
Energie der Stromversorgung angesprochen
was bedeutet das vor allem für das
ukrainische Militär für das Militär
glaube ich im Moment wenig weil die
Versorgung nachdem allen nach all dem
was wir wissen wenn wir erst mal
gesichert ist zumindest sind keine
logistischen Schwierigkeiten
verkündet worden das sind nicht bekannt
geworden und die treibstofflieferung die
Lebensmittel Lieferung die
Stromlieferung anders ukrainische
militärschein ungebrochen zu
funktionieren zumindest in den Gebieten
wo sie präsent sind vielen Dank für das
Gespräch bis zum nächsten Mal sehr gerne